- L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par madame Mélanie Thomin
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Mélanie Thomin: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, votre
réforme est un concentré
d'illusions perdues.
Alors que votre projet de texte
arrive à peine à la disposition
des parlementaires, les Français
ont déjà fait la démonstration de
leur opposition.
Votre ministre, Franck Riester,
l'avoue lui-même: les femmes
seront plus lourdement pénalisées
par votre report de l'âge.
Pour la génération 80, l'effort
des femmes sera 2 fois plus
important que l'effort fourni par
les hommes.
Au Smic, carrières partielles,
carrières fractionnées, vous
parlez des femmes sans les
humaniser.
Elles sont plusieurs à devoir
composer avec 40% de pension en
moins que les hommes.
Les femmes sont les premières
victimes de la décote.
Vous attaquez leurs belles années
après une vie de labeur.
Alors, votre revalorisation à 1200
euros brut, exclusivement pour les
carrières complètes, quelle
tromperie!
Et surtout, quelle plus-value,
quand la plupart de ces femmes
n'ont pas cotisé comme des hommes?
Vous avez trouvé une "solution
miracle": nous faire travailler
plus longtemps.
On ne transforme pas, on aggrave.
On comprend bien toute votre
contradiction.
Le suffrage universel avait
pourtant rendu son verdict.
Il n'y a pas de majorité absolue.
Madame la Première ministre,
considérant ces écueils majeurs
pour la défense des femmes et des
catégories moyennes et populaires,
quand votre gouvernement
compte-t-il retirer cette réforme?
Acclamations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je ne peux pas laisser dire que
notre projet ne protégerait pas
les femmes.
Au contraire...
Protestations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
S'il vous plaît!
On écoute la réponse de la
Première ministre.
Protestations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît, mes chers collègues.
C'est une séance de questions au
gouvernement.
Madame Mélanie Thomin a posé une
question.
J'attends la réponse du
gouvernement.
Ecoutez-la, s'il vous plaît.
- Elisabeth Borne: Au contraire,
nous réduisons les inégalités
inacceptables entre les femmes et
les hommes.
C'est au moment de la retraite.
Nous protégeons les femmes qui ont
des carrières incomplètes et
hachées.
Les femmes qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt, les femmes qui ont
des petites pensions, elles seront
les premières bénéficiaires de la
revalorisation.
Les femmes seront les premières
bénéficiaires de la revalorisation
des petites pensions.
Elles sont aujourd'hui plus
nombreuses à avoir cotisé avec des
revenus modestes.
Grâce à la revalorisation de la
retraite minimale, près d'un tiers
d'entre elles vont voir leur
pension augmenter.
Pour les retraités actuels, notre
projet bénéficie, là encore,
davantage aux femmes...
Protestations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît...
- Elisabeth Borne: Je le redis,
pour les retraités actuels, notre
projet bénéficie, là encore,
davantage aux femmes.
L'augmentation moyenne des petites
pensions sera donc soit plus
élevée pour elles que pour les
hommes.
Par ailleurs, nous allons prendre
en compte, pour le calcul des
droits, les trimestres en congé
parentale.
Les femmes qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt seront ainsi mieux
protégées.
20% des femmes doivent travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour bénéficier
d'une retraite à taux plein.
Malgré la hausse de l'âge légal,
nous maintenons à 67 ans l'âge de
départ à taux plein.
C'est pour les femmes qui ont des
interruptions de carrière souvent
subies.
Notre projet est juste et porteur
de progrès social.
Nous demandons à celles et ceux
qui le peuvent de travailler
progressivement plus longtemps, y
compris des femmes qui ont eu des
carrières complètes.
Cependant, les femmes continueront
à partir plus tôt que les hommes.
J'ajoute que les femmes
bénéficieront de pensions.
De fait, la réforme va contribuer
à réduire l'écart de pensions
entre les hommes et les
femmes.
Nous avons veillé, avec le
ministre Olivier Dussopt, en
construisant ce projet, à protéger
les plus fragiles, les plus
modestes, y compris les femmes.
Mais madame la députée, au-delà de
ce faux procès, j'espère que les
débats dans l'hémicycle vont nous
permettre de continuer à enrichir
le projet.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la Première
ministre.
Allez-y, madame Thomin.
- Mélanie Thomin: Nous savons bien
que vos mesures ne vont
s'appliquer qu'à une minorité de
femmes.
Partout en France, elles sont
mobilisées.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Lise
Magnier pour le groupe Horizons.
- Lise Magnier: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le ministre, un vent
glacial d'inquiétude et de
désarroi souffle sur nos plaines
agricoles depuis la semaine
dernière.
A quelques semaines des semis de
betteraves, les 24.000 planteurs
et l'ensemble des salariés de la
filière, tous des emplois situés
dans notre ruralité, ont appris
avec stupeur la décision de la
cour de justice de l'Union
Européenne d'interdire totalement
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes.
Lors de la campagne de 2020, la
première campagne sans
néonicotinoïdes, la production
dans mon département, la Marne,
avait baissé de plus de 25%.
En tout, 40% des planteurs avaient
connu une baisse de plus de 30% de
leur production.
Aujourd'hui, les planteurs
refusent de vivre à nouveau un tel
traumatisme.
Les industriels s'inquiètent
clairement pour leur outil, en cas
de baisse massive des rendements.
Plusieurs départements pourraient
subir des répercussions majeures.
La France est aujourd'hui le
premier pays producteur de sucre
d'Europe.
A ce stade, aucune solution n'a
fait ses preuves pour protéger les
cultures de betteraves du puceron
et de la jaunisse.
Malgré l'engagement collectif des
planteurs, des chercheurs et des
politiques, ce coup d'arrêt brutal
met en péril notre souveraineté
industrielle.
Ma question est donc double.
Afin de rassurer l'ensemble de la
filière, pouvez-vous nous assurer
qu'ils seront intégralement
indemnisés des potentielles pertes
liées à la jaunisse?
Pouvez-vous aussi confirmer qu'à
l'échelle européenne, aucune
distorsion de concurrence ne sera
possible?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci de votre
question, qui me permet d'éclairer
notre discussion par rapport à la
décision de la cour de justice de
l'Union Européenne.
On va arrêter l'utilisation en
enrobage
des néonicotinoïdes, avec
application immédiate.
Avant cela, il y avait des
dérogations.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons des
solutions sur la table, mais qui
ne sont pas abouties.
Nous devons prendre des décisions,
vis-à-vis des planteurs et de
l'ensemble de la filière.
Ils doivent être couverts en cas
de perte.
Deuxième élément: il faut faire en
sorte de rassurer les industriels.
Il y en a un certain nombre qui
ont besoin de betteraves.
Nous allons travailler pour être
au rendez-vous de cet élément-là.
Le troisième élément, c'est la
recherche et le développement.
Il faut l'accélérer, avec le
programme qui avait été lancé,
notamment.
La démagogie, ce serait de dire
qu'il ne faut pas respecter le
droit européen.
D'ailleurs, ce n'est pas ce que
vous avez dit.
La démagogie, ce serait de faire
croire qu'il y a d'autres voies
possibles.
La responsabilité, c'est de dire
que nous avons besoin de cette
filière pour un certain nombre
d'éléments.
C'est ça qui sera développé par le
gouvernement, pour donner de la
visibilité à cette filière.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Florian
Chauche pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Florian Chauche: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle, le président de la
République a déclaré que nombre de
nos compatriotes avaient voté pour
lui pour faire barrage aux idées
de l'extrême droite.
Il a dit que ce vote l'obligeait
pour les années à venir.
Que de chemin parcouru, depuis!
Le président de la République se
sent légitime pour repousser l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite.
Pourtant, les Françaises et les
Français ont fait le choix de ne
pas vous donner de majorité
absolue.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes nombreux,
sur ces bancs, à être contre le
report à 64 ans de l'âge de départ
à la retraite.
C'est pourquoi vous faites le
choix de passer en force.
Vous dégainez l'article 47.1 pour
contraindre les débats
parlementaires à 20 jours.
C'est une disposition jamais
utilisée depuis 1958.
Vous refusez que nous puissions
discuter, parce que vous avez peur
du résultat.
Que de mépris pour notre Assemblée
nationale et pour le débat
parlementaire!
Les sondages montrent que 7
Français sur 10 sont opposés à
votre réforme.
Même quand 2 millions de salariés
font le choix de manifester, et de
perdre une journée de salaire,
votre porte-parole répond qu'il
voit 1 million de personnes à
convaincre.
Nous ne voulons pas renoncer.
Vous devez respecter les
Françaises et les Français.
Ils sont opposés à votre projet et
vous l'ont fait savoir.
Si vous êtes si sûrs de votre
projet, pourquoi ne pas laisser
notre Assemblée nationale
débattre, ou même les Françaises
et les Français trancher la
question par référendum?
Est-ce que vous allez à nouveau
utiliser l'article 49.3?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt,
ministre du Travail, du Plein
emploi et de l'Insertion.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Vous avez évoqué le contexte de
l'élection présidentielle.
Le président de la République,
alors candidat, avait indiqué de
manière claire sa volonté de mener
une réforme des retraites.
Il avait indiqué qu'à ses yeux, la
méthode la plus efficace était de
porter l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans.
Vous avez dit qu'il y avait des
Français qui, au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle, avaient
voté pour lui malgré cette
réforme, et sans porter leur
soutien à cette réforme.
Nous le savons, mais ces mêmes
Français savent les engagements
qu'il a pris.
La réforme que nous portons est
nécessaire, parce que le déficit
est avéré.
Il atteint 12,5 milliards d'euros
en 2025.
Vous nous interrogez sur la
procédure parlementaire.
Vous faites référence à l'article
47.1.
Nous n'avons pas lieu de le
déclencher, ni de l'actionner.
Il dit que les projets de loi de
financement de la Sécurité sociale
ont un délai de 20 jours pour
examiner un texte.
J'ai présenté hier un texte de 14
articles, pour 20 jours.
Je crois que la représentation
nationale aura très largement le
temps d'être éclairée, par ses
débats, par les débats en
commission, et par le débat
public.
A la fin du débat, il y aura un
vote souverain de l'Assemblée
nationale.
Je ne préjuge du vote de personne.
Mais ce vote sera légitime et
permettra de mettre en oeuvre
cette réforme.
La seule chose qui pourrait
bloquer le débat, ce serait
l'obstruction.
La balle est dans votre camp.
- Florian Chauche: Les Français
vous donnent rendez-vous le 31
janvier, pour la prochaine
manifestation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Peytavie.
- Sébastien Peytavie: Merci.
Equilibre budgétaire, système
déficitaire...
Depuis maintenant deux semaines,
les bons soldats du gouvernement
sont au rendez-vous sur les
plateaux télé et martèlent les
mêmes éléments de langage.
Est-ce qu'il y a une urgence à
réformer, monsieur le ministre?
Non.
Ni les économistes, ni le comité
de retraite ne vous donne raison.
La seule urgence pour vous est de
baisser le déficit à 3%.
C'est une réforme des finances
publiques.
Nous vous alertons depuis des
années.
C'est la faillite d'un système de
santé et d'un modèle de protection
sociale désormais à double
vitesse.
Vieillir en bonne santé devient un
privilège de classe.
L'urgence, elle est du côté des
salariés, qui voient chaque jour
leurs conditions de travail se
dégrader davantage.
Vous souhaitez augmenter les
pensions de retraite?
Vous n'avez qu'à augmenter les
salaires.
L'un ne va pas sans l'autre.
Je pense aux soignants de
l'hôpital de Pontoise, à 80% en
arrêt maladie.
Ils sont nombreux à ne pas pouvoir
partir plus tôt à la retraite.
Ces premières lignes, à qui vous
promettez une première prise en
compte de la pénibilité au
travail, vous leur offrez qu'un
fonds lié à l'usure.
C'est la honte, monsieur le
ministre!
Le budget de la santé ne suit pas
le cours de l'inflation.
Comment comptez-vous réellement
prendre en compte la pénibilité
pour les métiers du soin et de
l'accompagnement?
Acclamations
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Nous sommes
heureux que votre état de santé
vous permette de nous rejoindre et
de participer à nos travaux.
J'ai un point de désaccord, et un
point d'accord avec vous.
Nous considérons que la réforme
est nécessaire.
Vous évoquez le conseil de gestion
des retraites.
Sur 10 ans, c'est 150 milliards
d'euros de dettes accumulés, si
nous ne faisons rien.
Nous ne partageons pas ce degré
d'urgence.
Nous sommes convaincus qu'il y a
urgence, pas vous.
Mais je vous rejoins sur la
question de la prise en compte de
la pénibilité des soignants.
Les chiffres sont extrêmement
clairs.
Plus de 40% des soignants sont
exposés à des contraintes de
rythme et d'intensité.
La situation aujourd'hui est très
complexe.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le dire hier
en commission des Affaires
sociales.
Que vous soyez aide-soignant,
infirmier recruté avant ou après
2010, vous ne disposez pas des
mêmes protections.
Ce que nous faisons sur ce projet,
ça va permettre aux soignants d'y
accéder.
Nous avons mis en place une
nouveauté.
J'ai cru comprendre que vous la
trouviez insuffisante.
100 millions d'euros par an vont
permettre de financer la
prévention de l'usure, notamment.
C'est la première fois que ça
existe.
Ce sont des montants conséquents.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Eric Girardin.
- Eric Girardin: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail,
du Plein emploi et de l'Insertion.
En France, nous disposons d'un
système de solidarité, dans lequel
les actifs cotisent pour financer
le repos de nos aînés.
Or, la démographie et la réalité
économique ont fortement changé,
depuis l'après-guerre.
Si le seuil de la retraite est
positif, le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites prévoit un déficit
durable de notre système des
retraites allant jusqu'à -21
milliards d'euros en 2035.
Je tiens à rappeler devant tous
nos collègues cette réalité
économique et budgétaire.
Gouverner, c'est prévoir.
C'est pourquoi notre
responsabilité collective est de
garantir une retraite à nos
enfants et à nos petits-enfants,
en s'assurant de la pérennité de
notre système de retraite et de
son équilibre financier.
Nous proposons une réforme
progressive.
Nous voulons protéger notamment
les travailleurs handicapés et
augmenter le minimum de pension de
100 euros par mois pour une
carrière complète.
Nous allons aussi créer un index
senior.
Monsieur le ministre, en
complément de tous ces progrès,
vous avez indiqué en commission
vouloir avancer sur l'amélioration
de la formation et sur les
modalités qui permettent à des
étudiants et à des stagiaires de
racheter des trimestres.
Dans un cadre où on rallonge la
durée de cotisation et l'âge de
départ à la retraite, alors que
les conditions actuelles de rachat
sont relativement restrictives, ne
pensez-vous pas que simplifier le
recours à ces mécanismes de rachat
des trimestres permettrait aux
jeunes de mieux s'approprier et de
mieux s'impliquer dans la
construction de leur propre
retraite?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Je ne vais pas
revenir sur l'équilibre général de
la réforme.
Vous l'avez rappelé avec justesse.
Mais je me concentre sur la
question que vous posez concernant
les dispositifs de rachat de
trimestres.
Il y a des possibilités de rachat
de trimestres, effectivement.
Nous devons améliorer la formation
telle qu'elle est adressée aux
assurés.
Nous devons aussi desserrer les
contraintes, pour que cette
possibilité de rachat se fasse à
un moment où les assurés sont en
capacité de le faire et dans des
conditions qui soient les plus
abordables et les plus
acceptables.
Il y a aussi une possibilité qui
existe et qui est peu connue.
C'est la possibilité de racheter
les trimestres de stage.
Les conditions de rachat de
trimestres de stage sont
particulièrement avantageuses.
Elles font que le trimestre peut
être racheté à hauteur de 440
euros.
La loi de 2013, qui a permis ce
rachat de stage, fixe à un délai
de deux ans après la fin du stage
la possibilité de rachat.
C'est trop court.
Deux ans après son stage, on peut
encore être en études ou dans une
situation professionnelle qui ne
permet pas le rachat, y compris
pour les montants ainsi fixés.
Je suis totalement ouvert à
pouvoir aménager et améliorer ces
dispositifs de rachat de stage.
On pourrait étendre le délai de
rachat et déterminer un âge
jusqu'auquel on pourrait racheter
ses trimestres de stage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Bentz.
- Christophe Bentz: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
l'INSEE vient de publier les
chiffres de la natalité pour 2022.
Ils sont préoccupants.
Il y a 19.000 naissances de moins
que l'année précédente.
La natalité française enregistre
un recul historique.
Dans le même temps, la mortalité
augmente.
Le solde naturel est au plus bas.
Jamais les Français n'ont eu aussi
peu d'enfants, depuis près de 80
ans.
La démocratie est un enjeu
essentiel pour l'avenir de notre
société.
La natalité et le soutien aux
familles doivent être à la base de
toute politique, pour redonner
confiance aux Français.
En parallèle, vous vous apprêtez à
imposer aux Français une réforme
des retraites injuste, indigne, et
déconnectée de toute réalité
humaine.
Vous êtes aveuglés par votre
obsession comptable.
Vous considérez que, puisque
l'espérance de vie a augmenté, les
Français doivent travailler plus
longtemps.
Mais la question humaine et
sociale est: vivons-nous en
meilleure santé?
La réponse est malheureusement
non.
Il n'y a pas de système de
retraite par répartition sans
renouvellement des générations.
Or, vous oubliez d'encourager le
principal facteur de croissance
économique: la natalité.
Elle renouvelle justement les
générations.
Soutenir une démographie dynamique
sur le long terme, c'est la
garantie d'équilibrer durablement
le système de retraites.
C'est assurer une solidarité
naturelle entre générations.
Lors de la présidentielle, nous
avions proposé un arsenal de
mesures de bon sens pour soutenir
les familles françaises.
La relance de la natalité est un
impératif pour la France.
Elle doit être une priorité
nationale.
Madame la Première ministre,
qu'allez-vous faire pour doter
enfin la France d'une ambitieuse
politique de relance de la
natalité?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Vous évoquez la question
démographique.
Je fais le lien avec la réforme
des retraites que nous menons.
Nous avons une situation
démographique qui n'est pas
nouvelle.
Dans les années 90, il y avait 3
cotisants pour 10 retraités.
Nous sommes passés à 1,7 actif
pour 1 retraité aujourd'hui.
Cela tient peut-être à des
considérations sur la natalité.
Cela tient aussi à l'augmentation
de l'espérance de vie.
C'est une bonne nouvelle.
En 2040, nous serons à 4 actifs
pour 1 retraités.
C'est l'explication à la réforme
que nous menons.
S'il y a moins d'actifs pour
financer les retraites, ça va
avoir des conséquences.
Est-ce que nous pouvons soutenir
les questions de natalité?
Nous le faisons.
Il y a un certain nombre de
mesures qui vont dans ce sens.
Le fait de faire en sorte que les
trimestres puissent être pris en
compte pour l'éligibilité au
dispositif de carrières longues ou
de retraite minimum, c'est une
manière de mieux protéger les
femmes, notamment.
Vous avez parlé de natalité en
général.
J'ai eu l'occasion de dire qu'il y
aurait d'autres sujets.
Permettez-moi de conclure en ayant
en tête les positions que vous
avez pu prendre sur la loi
relative à l'IVG, par exemple.
L'objectif de cette majorité sera
de soutenir toutes les familles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Xavier
Breton.
- Xavier Breton: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
jamais la natalité française n'a
été aussi basse depuis 1946.
723.000, c'est le nombre de
naissances en France en tout.
Les chiffres de 2012 paraissent
lointains.
Le nombre d'enfants par femme est
tombé à 1,8.
Il manque désormais chaque année
40 à 50.000 naissances pour
assurer le renouvellement des
générations.
Madame la Première ministre, nous
devons effectivement nous alerter
de ces chiffres.
Pourtant, ces chiffres ne sont pas
étonnants.
Depuis 10 ans, des choix sont
faits pour rompre délibérément, et
par idéologie, avec la politique
familiale de notre pays, qui
faisait pourtant l'objet d'un
consensus politique très large.
Depuis 10 ans, sous le mandat de
François Hollande d'abord, sous le
mandat d'Emmanuel Macron ensuite,
tout objectif de soutien à la
natalité est systématiquement
écarté, et les atteintes portées
aux allocations familiales, au
congé parental, et au quotient
familial, pénalisent tout
particulièrement les familles des
classes moyennes et des classes
défavorisées.
Alors, madame la Première
ministre, allez-vous réagir face à
cette baisse historique de la
natalité?
Allez-vous enfin refaire du
soutien à la natalité une
véritable priorité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Merci.
Vous avez raison.
Comme vous, nous nous inquiétons
des chiffres de la natalité dans
notre pays.
723.000 naissances, c'est un plus
bas historique.
Pour autant, avec une fécondité
d'1,8, notre pays est l'un des
plus féconds d'Europe.
Mon rôle est de favoriser le
rapprochement entre ce taux de
fécondité et celui du désir
d'enfant dans notre pays.
Il est de 2,4 par femme.
Ce qui cause la différence,
c'est la question de l'équilibre
entre vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle.
C'est pour ça que le président de
la République, tout au long de sa
campagne, a promis de mettre en
place un service public de la
petite enfance, pour favoriser la
natalité dans notre pays,
permettre de réduire cet écart
entre le taux de fécondité et le
désir d'enfant dans notre pays.
Ce service public de la petite
enfance, j'ai lancé un débat dans
le cadre du Conseil national de la
refondation pour y travailler au
niveau national, avec les
associations d'élus, avec les
associations familiales, avec la
Caisse Nationale des Allocations
Familiales.
Nous aimerions créer 200.000
places d'accueil d'ici 2030 et
accompagner les collectivités à
développer cette offre.
C'est une politique qui va
permettre de mieux équilibrer la
vie familiale et la vie
professionnelle, de renforcer
l'équilibre entre les femmes et
les hommes, et de lutter contre
les inégalités de destin.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Breton?
Il vous reste 19 secondes.
- Xavier Breton: Merci.
Les collectivités locales ne vous
ont pas attendu pour mettre en
place des services de petite
enfance.
Elles le font déjà.
Vous avez des responsabilités au
niveau fiscal, avec le plafond du
quotient familial.
C'est aussi au niveau du budget
famille.
C'est aussi avec le congé
parental, qui ne doit pas être
idéologique, mais basé sur la
réalité des familles.
C'est là qu'on vous attend.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à est à madame
Brigitte Klinkert.
- Brigitte Klinkert: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat chargée des
Affaires européennes.
Dimanche a marqué une nouvelle
étape dans la relation d'amitié
qui lie la France et l'Allemagne.
Les cérémonies organisées à la
Sorbonne et dans l'hémicycle ont
été l'occasion de manifester la
force des liens qui nous unissent,
60 ans après la signature du
traité de l'Elysée.
Après ce traité, consacré à la
réconciliation, le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle a posé le
principe de la convergence de
manière générale mais aussi
explicitement dans le domaine
économique.
La France et l'Allemagne se
doivent donc d'harmoniser leur
politique.
L'assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande est au travail.
Elle veillera à la réalisation des
projets inscrits au traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle et à
l'harmonisation de la
transposition des directives
européennes dans nos deux pays.
Aux côtés des initiatives
gouvernementales et citoyennes,
l'Assemblée nationale et notre
assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande ont plus que
jamais un rôle central à jouer.
Comme évoqué par le président de
la République à la Sorbonne,
l'Allemagne et la France doivent
devenir pionnières dans la
refondation de notre Europe
ensemble.
Il nous revient donc d'adopter les
mesures adaptées pour ne pas subir
les événements mais au contraire
pour agir, en amis et partenaires.
Oui, Français et Allemands doivent
travailler ensemble pour renforcer
le rôle de l'Europe, pour bâtir
une véritable souveraineté
européenne.
Madame la ministre, quelles sont
les étapes concrètes à venir?
Les partenariats que vous allez
développer pour rendre cette
collaboration franco-allemande
toujours plus tangible pour les
yeux de nos concitoyens.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Laurence
Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Madame la députée, ce dimanche 22
janvier a effectivement pris un
sens particulier avec le retour de
la guerre sur notre continent.
Il s'agissait de célébrer la paix
entre la France et l'Allemagne,
symbolisée par le traité de
l'Elysée et ses 60 ans.
D'ailleurs, je veux remercier tous
ceux qui étaient présents et qui
contribuent à faire vivre l'amitié
franco-allemande, de même que la
présidente de l'Assemblée et sa
déclaration commune avec celle de
l'assemblée allemande.
C'était le premier Conseil des
ministres franco-allemands avec
les deux nouveaux gouvernements et
ils ont présenté une feuille de
route commune avec certains
projets.
J'en profite pour excuser la
ministre, Catherine Colonna, qui
ne peut être là aujourd'hui.
Il faut affirmer un soutien sans
faille à l'Ukraine.
De par la défense, l'industrie,
avec des projets auxquels
l'Allemagne va participer pour la
sécurité énergétique de notre
continent, des programmes de
recherche.
Monsieur Clément Beaune a créé le
premier billet de train
franco-allemand pour les jeunes.
60.000 vont en bénéficier
gratuitement.
Il y a aussi un programme de
jeunes talents franco-allemands.
C'est la jeune génération qui fera
vivre cette unité et pas les
dissensions de l'extrême droite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Fabien
Roussel.
- Fabien Roussel: Les hausses de
factures de gaz et d'électricité
suscitent au moins autant de colère
que votre réforme des retraites.
Des locataires de HLM doivent
payer,
et ils ont des charges de 450
euros.
Des entreprises se demandent
comment payer leurs factures cette
année.
+30.000 euros pour une
boulangerie, +30.000 euros pour un
boucher.
Les filets de sécurité font
réduire les investissements pour
les boucliers tarifaires que vous
mettez en place.
Cela révèle aussi l'insuffisance
des finances publiques.
Nos réserves de gaz sont au plus
haut point mais depuis que la
France est soumise au funeste
règlement de la libre concurrence
européenne, les tarifs explosent.
Nous produisons de l'énergie à
moins de 50 euros du mégawatt.
Elle est revendue 5 à 10 fois plus
cher à cause de la spéculation
européenne.
La France est une grande nation
qui a su bâtir son indépendance
énergétique.
Avec notre proposition de loi, 110
députés de tous bords vous
demandent de rétablir des tarifs
régulés pour tous: entreprises,
communes, foyers, à prix coûtant.
Quand la France va-t-elle sortir
de la spéculation européenne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Monsieur le président Fabien
Roussel, je vais peut-être vous
surprendre, mais mis à part la
remarque sur les retraites, je
suis en accord avec ce que vous
venez de dire.
Vous êtes pour l'indépendance
énergétique, nous aussi.
Vous êtes pour le renforcement de
la filière nucléaire, nous aussi.
Vous défendez les entreprises, les
boulangers, les bouchers, nous
aussi.
Nous voulons les protéger contre
l'augmentation des factures.
Nous avons prévu de mettre en
place un bouclier tarifaire à 280
euros le mégawatt heure pour les
très petites entreprises de
France, en particulier les
boulangers qui subissent la double
peine de l'augmentation des tarifs
de l'électricité et de
l'augmentation du prix des
matières premières.
Je profite de votre question pour
lancer un appel solennel à toutes
les très petites entreprises qui
ne se sont pas déclarées comme
très petites entreprises auprès
des fournisseurs d'énergie: il
faut qu'elles le fassent dans les
jours qui viennent.
Vous êtes 1,5 million de petites
entreprises éligibles aux tarifs
régulés.
Il n'y a que la moitié d'entre
elles qui vont en bénéficier parce
que l'autre moitié a choisi les
tarifs de marché et ne s'est pas
déclarée auprès de son
fournisseur.
Vous avez droit au bouclier
tarifaire.
Il faut vous déclarer comme TPE et
retirer le formulaire, il faut
aller sur son espace client pour
se déclarer comme très petites
entreprises et bénéficier de la
protection.
Vous avez droit à la protection
que vous réclamez légitimement
pour nos très petites entreprises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Benjamin
Saint-Huile.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
Olivier Dussopt.
Qui veut de votre réforme des
retraites?
Il semblerait qu'il y ait la
majorité présidentielle, tenue par
les engagements du candidat, que
Bruxelles vous presse ardemment de
prendre les mesures, et que la
droite hésite.
Je rappelle à mes collègues de
droite que vous avez un mandat
d'opposition.
Qui veut de cette réforme?
Les organisations patronales,
unanimes, qui vous applaudissent.
Les Français, eux, n'en veulent
pas!
Ils étaient dans les rues,
partout.
Nous voulons vous parler de
l'emploi des seniors, de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes, de
la prime de vie chère.
Créons les conditions d'un débat
apaisé.
Une seule mesure cristallise la
colère et l'incompréhension des
Français: le recul de l'âge légal
à 64 ans.
Retirez cette mesure et créons un
débat apaisé.
La balle est dans votre camp.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt:
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci à vous,
monsieur le député.
Je crois que c'est la troisième
fois que je le répète dans cette
séance: notre système est
déficitaire.
Vous avez vu le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites.
Le système est déficitaire dès
2023 et va se creuser.
Equilibrer le système est une
responsabilité qui nous incombe.
Nous améliorons l'emploi des
seniors, la pénibilité, les
carrières longues, l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et nous
équilibrons le budget.
Ce sont les objectifs que nous
poursuivons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Benjamin Saint-Huile?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: On peut
parler de la réforme et de
l'équilibre du système, mais cette
réforme n'est pas une réforme des
retraites, c'est une réforme qui
est celle des finances publiques.
Vous n'interrogez pas le capital.
Vous n'interrogez pas le
patrimoine.
Vous pensez que vous faites preuve
de courage, mais ce courage, je
l'assimile à une surdité coupable.
Vous menez une procédure
inflammable à un moment où les
Français sont à bout.
Je le dis aux oppositions: si nous
sommes intelligents ensemble, nous
ferons plier le gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Applaudissements
- Olivier Dussopt: Qu'aurions-nous
dû faire?
Baisser les pensions?
Mettre à mal les retraités?
Augmenter la fiscalité et revenir
sur la politique de l'emploi?
Augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires?
Entraver l'arrivée au plein
emploi?
Est-ce que vous proposez d'aller à
la ruine, de laisser le système
filer?
Huées
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Il faut
écouter le ministre.
Monsieur Benjamin Saint-Huile,
vous avez épuisé votre temps de
parole.
- Olivier Dussopt: Nous croyons au
travail, à la croissance, à la
prospérité et nous croyons à de
bonnes retraites.
Ne pas le faire, c'est mettre en
marche la machine adéquate, la
machine à petites pensions et la
machine à inégalités.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Sabine
Thillaye.
- Sabine Thillaye: Merci.
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
parler des 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée.
C'est pour moi toujours un
miracle, la réconciliation
franco-allemande, et un miracle
pour moi, arrivée il y a 40 ans en
France, sans parler français, et
de pouvoir aujourd'hui prendre la
parole sans que cela ne pose de
problème.
Je mesure le chemin parcouru.
Je voudrais parler du 9 mai 1950.
Le discours de Robert Schumann a
été un acte fondateur qui a permis
cette réconciliation
franco-allemande.
C'est la France qui a tendu la
main à l'Allemagne avec énormément
d'audace et de vision.
Elle doit être plus fière que ça.
Nous sommes attachés à l'Etat de
droit.
Nous sommes attachés à la
démocratie.
Nous sommes derrière l'Union
Européenne et nous soutenons sans
faille le peuple ukrainien qui
nous montre une chose très
importante: il n'y a pas de
bonheur sans liberté, il n'y a pas
de liberté sans courage, sans
audace.
Avons-nous encore cette audace?
Nous avons accordé le statut de
candidat à l'Ukraine.
Ca va être une discussion très
difficile mais il faut élargir.
Nous avons par contre aussi besoin
d'une réforme institutionnelle de
l'Union Européenne pour qu'elle
soit en capacité d'agir.
Madame la secrétaire d'Etat, vous
avez mis en place avec votre
homologue un forum d'experts.
Vous êtes venue parler des
dispositions qu'on peut prendre
pour donner un coup de pouce dans
cette Union Européenne qui doit
faire face à des défis
extraordinaires aujourd'hui.
Quelles sont les démarches à
suivre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Laurence Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Merci.
Parmi les projets que l'on a créés
et qui ont été mis en oeuvre dans
le cadre du 60e anniversaire du
traité de l'Elysée, il y a la mise
en place d'un groupe d'experts
indépendants français et allemands
pour réfléchir à l'évolution des
institutions européennes.
Nous l'avons fait pour la
simplicité de son action,
l'efficacité et la rapidité.
Pour la protection de ces valeurs,
notamment l'Etat de droit, qui est
menacé dans beaucoup de pays à
l'intérieur de l'Union Européenne
et à ses frontières, ces experts
français et allemands rendront à
l'automne 2023 des propositions
qui viseront à accélérer,
simplifier et rendre plus efficace
le fonctionnement de l'Union
Européenne, la rapprocher des
citoyens et étudier comment la
main tendue aux pays aux
frontières de l'Union Européenne
peut se transformer en proposition
d'adhésion tout en maintenant le
fonctionnement efficace de l'Union
Européenne.
La sécurité de notre continent
passe par là et la sauvegarde de
nos valeurs démocratiques aussi.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Hervé de
Lépinau.
- Hervé de Lépinau: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
Je crois que c'est votre journée.
Après l'abandon des politiques
familiales, voici la soumission à
la volonté bruxelloise de baisser
les pensions de retraite et une
immigration de masse du fait de la
diminution du nombre d'actifs.
Vous êtes l'héritier assumé des
politiques UMP et PS, tant votre
parcours politique ressemble à de
la godille.
Le dispositif créé par le
gouvernement Jospin à l'aube des
années 2000 devait initialement
permettre de soutenir notre régime
des retraites face au choc
générationnel du baby-boom.
En 2010, votre nouveau compagnon
de route, Eric Woerth, avait cru
bon de mettre fin aux abondements
de l'Etat dans ce fonds, lui
préférant à des classements au
profit de la caisse
d'amortissement.
L'élection d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 n'a pas inversé la tendance.
Ce fonds ne représente plus que
21,5 milliards d'euros.
La Caisse d'Amortissement de la
Dette Sociale aura apuré son
passif aux alentours de 2030.
Le fonds de réserve des retraites
devrait retrouver son objectif
initial, compenser le déficit des
retraites.
Gouverner, c'est prévoir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Olivier Dussopt?
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, vous êtes presque
outrancier.
"Gouverner, c'est prévoir": c'est
ce que nous faisons, face à un
système en déficit.
Nous prenons des mesures pour
améliorer le système et permettre
sa pérennité pour nos enfants,
pour nos petits-enfants, pour
permettre de garantir le système
par répartition.
Le projet que vous avez défendu
pendant l'élection présidentielle
était illisible et inefficace.
Il coûterait 10 milliards d'euros
aux dépenses publiques.
Il n'y a rien de mal à
rééquilibrer les comptes publics.
Je sais l'importance de la
maîtrise des comptes publics pour
la souveraineté de la nation.
Si vous êtes attaché à la
souveraineté, vous devriez savoir
accompagner les efforts de celles
et ceux qui la garantissent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Rome.
- Sébastien Rome: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Sur les réseaux sociaux, vous
invitiez nos PME, TPE, boulangers,
à télécharger un formulaire pour
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire.
Pourquoi?
C'est un enchevêtrement confus
organisé en marché volatile où les
prix sont sans lien avec la
production mais totalement avec la
spéculation.
Les Françaises et les Français
veulent vivre de leur travail et
non de chèques cadeaux ou de
boucliers percés.
Il existe une solution protectrice
pour nos entreprises et nos
artisans et l'ensemble des
Français: les tarifs réglementés
de la vente de l'électricité,
déconnectés du marché!
En commission des finances, nous
vous avions alerté dès l'automne
sur l'impact de l'inflation sur
les commerçants et artisans.
Vous avez préféré attendre.
Cet hiver, en découvrant l'impact
de la volatilité des prix, tous
ont été convaincus d'une évidence:
il faut un retour aux tarifs
réglementés.
Pour cela, il faut sortir du
marché européen de l'électricité,
comme l'a fait le gouvernement
espagnol.
Un rétablissement des tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité qui
rémunère uniquement le coût de
production, du transport et de la
commercialisation aurait rétabli
des prix justes.
Combien de temps allez-vous
attendre encore?
Quand allez-vous enfin mettre un
terme à la concurrence du marché
de l'énergie alors que c'est une
nécessité absolue pour nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Sébastien Rome, je veux vous
rassurer.
Les ménages en France restent
parmi les mieux protégés en Europe
grâce au bouclier tarifaire
que nous avons mis en place sur
l'électricité et le gaz depuis 2
ans, comme aucun autre pays
européen n'a su le faire.
C'est ce qui nous permet d'avoir
le taux d'inflation parmi les plus
bas de tous les pays de la zone
euro depuis 2 ans, parce que nous
avons protégé nos compatriotes.
Pour les petites entreprises, je
vais vous rejoindre, pour une
fois: je vous redis que les tarifs
régulés de vente bénéficient à 1,5
million de très petites
entreprises.
Pour en bénéficier, elles doivent
se déclarer auprès de leurs
fournisseurs d'énergie si elles ne
l'ont pas fait.
Il y a une moitié qui ne l'a pas
fait.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Pouvez-vous
écouter le ministre?
C'est insupportable!
- Bruno Le Maire: On aimerait
pouvoir s'adresser aux Français
sans être interrompu sans cesse
lorsqu'on apporte des réponses à
leurs interrogations et leurs
angoisses.
Je vous redis que les petites
entreprises, pour qu'elles
bénéficient de tarifs régulés de
vente et du bouclier tarifaire,
elles doivent se déclarer pour en
bénéficier.
Pouvez-vous ne pas m'interrompre
lorsque je donne une réponse?
Les très petites entreprises
doivent se déclarer auprès de
leurs fournisseurs d'énergie.
Je regrette de ne pas pouvoir
donner de réponses complètes aux
Français parce que les députés de
la NUPES nous empêchent de nous
exprimer!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Julien Dive.
- Julien Dive: Merci.
200 millions d'euros, ce sont les
pertes de rendement estimées par
les betteraviers après l'épidémie
de jaunisse qui a décimé les
cultures en 2020.
Jeudi 19 janvier 2023, la cour de
justice de l'Union Européenne a
jugé illégales les dérogations
accordées aux agriculteurs sur
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes.
C'est un coup de massue pour la
filière des betteraves.
Cela fait des semaines que l'on
entend le ministre de la
Transition écologique se
positionner contre les
betteraviers.
Il a fallu un arrêté brutal pour
que nous puissions sortir de
l'impasse.
Vous proposez un plan d'action en
soutien à la filière, mais il nous
faut des engagements concrets et
durables.
Le plan national de recherche
d'innovation que vous mentionnez
ne demande pas que de l'argent,
mais aussi du temps, et le temps
de nos betteraviers est compté.
Vous évoquez un accompagnement
financier.
Nos producteurs de pommes de terre
se souviennent des promesses non
tenues.
Où comptez-vous chercher les
fonds?
Quelles seront les règles?
Y aura-t-il un plafond, des
franchises?
Aucun pays membres ne peut déroger
aux
produits cités, sauf l'Allemagne,
deuxième producteur en Europe
après la France, qui utilise des
insecticides numérisés interdits
en France.
Les mêmes règles doivent
s'appliquer pour tous.
Allez-vous monter au créneau pour
proposer l'instauration des mêmes
règles au sein de l'Union
Européenne pour préserver notre
souveraineté agricole et permettre
aux agriculteurs français de
fournir les betteraves sucrières
dont nous avons besoin chaque
jour?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Vous connaissez le sujet, vous
avez travaillé à la question.
Il était prévu que nous sortions
en 3 ans de leur semence.
La cour de justice européenne a
interrompu le processus dans
lequel nous nous étions lancés.
Nous attendions une troisième
année d'expérimentation.
C'est ce qui avait été décidé par
le gouvernement.
Des solutions, ce n'est pas de la
magie.
C'est de la recherche, du temps et
de l'innovation qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre.
La décision de la cour de justice
va s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
pays européens.
S'il y avait un besoin, nous
activerions la clause de
sauvegarde.
Voilà pour les enrobages.
Vous me demandez des
engagements par rapport à la
filière.
L'intégralité des pertes dues à la
jaunisse sera couverte.
C'est dans l'urgence.
On a besoin de le dire aux
planteurs.
Il faut continuer la recherche.
C'est long, vous avez raison, mais
il n'y a pas d'autre choix.
Nous étions de toute façon dans la
tendance d'interdire les
néonicotinoïdes.
Il faut que nous puissions envoyer
ces messages à la filière.
Cette filière est très importante
pour la France.
Elle compte beaucoup en termes de
souveraineté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Michèle Peyron: Merci.
La cour de justice de l'Union
Européenne a décidé de bannir les
néonicotinoïdes.
Suite à leur interdiction en 2018,
et une épidémie de jaunisse qui
avait décimé les exploitations de
betteraves, toute une filière
avait été mise en danger.
Nous souhaitons des moyens massifs
pour la recherche, pour laisser le
temps à une alternative viable.
En clair, pas d'interdiction sans
solution.
J'ai rencontré les agriculteurs de
Seine-et-Marne, ce vendredi.
Leur inquiétude est forte et
réelle.
Cette décision est brutale, en
pleine campagne de semence.
Plusieurs pays européens sont
moins respectueux de
l'environnement.
Les recherches sont également
toujours en cours.
Je souhaite assurer que le groupe
Renaissance est aux côtés des
agriculteurs et partage leurs
inquiétudes.
C'est aujourd'hui 45.000 emplois
de la filière française qui sont
menacés suite à cette décision.
Il existe un vrai risque d'abandon
de la part des agriculteurs de
cette culture, qui serait peu
rentable.
Les solutions sont bien avancées,
mais peu satisfaisantes.
Les agriculteurs ont besoin de
signes forts de notre part.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles sont
les solutions à court terme pour
les agriculteurs dont les semences
sont en cours?
Quelles solutions alternatives?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Vous êtes dans un département
éminemment concerné par ce sujet.
C'est un département dont on
connaît l'importance en termes de
production de betteraves.
C'est aussi un des départements
les plus touchés par les épisodes
de jaunisse.
Je ne reviens pas sur ce que j'ai
dit, mais évidemment, le
gouvernement sera au rendez-vous.
Il a aussi été au rendez-vous pour
la filière viticole ou pour la
filière porcine.
Nous voulons préserver la
souveraineté alimentaire de notre
pays.
Nous avons besoin de conforter le
monde agricole.
Il y a un plan d'accompagnement
sur 2023 qui devrait pouvoir
couvrir les pertes sur la
jaunisse.
Le deuxième élément, c'est la
recherche.
La voie la plus prometteuse, ce
sera la recherche au niveau des
semences.
Il y a des techniques de semences
qui devraient permettre d'avoir
des semences résistantes à la
jaunisse.
Deuxième élément, sur la question
industrielle, on aura besoin de
travailler avec la filière pour
assurer que les outils industriels
soient préservés.
Sans outil industriel, il n'y a
pas de planteurs.
C'est une préoccupation
importante.
Tous les sujets de cette nature,
il faut les poser au niveau
européen.
Dès lors que les décisions sont
différentes en France et en
Europe, cela crée des situations
inacceptables.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Béatrice
Descamps.
- Béatrice Descamps: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à Charlotte
Caubel.
Madame la ministre, la semaine
dernière, la création d'un
dispositif d'aide d'urgence à
destination des victimes de
violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales a été officialisé.
Cela a des conséquences
dramatiques sur les enfants.
Cela crée des traumatismes
profonds, aux séquelles souvent
longues.
Cela est mis en avant par la
littérature scientifique.
De nombreux travaux législatifs
ont eu lieu.
Le grenelle sur les violences
conjugales avait donné leur place
aux enfants.
Les chiffres actuels restent
pourtant dramatiques.
398.000 enfants sont co-victimes.
42% d'entre eux ont moins de 6
ans.
Parmi les femmes victimes, 70%
d'entre elles ont été témoins,
durant leur propre enfance, de
violences conjugales, qui ont
altéré leur discernement de
comportement face à ces violences.
D'où l'indispensable nécessité
d'agir dès l'enfance, agir le plus
tôt possible.
Madame la ministre, pour
accompagner ces enfants, mais
aussi de nombreux adultes, car la
réponse n'est pas toujours
judiciaire, nous manquons
aujourd'hui cruellement de moyens
humains.
Comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de faire face à ce
constat dramatique, accentué par
les inégalités territoriales, et
de tenter de permettre à ces
personnes, à ces enfants, de
retrouver une vie normale, tant
que faire se peut?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à...
Charlotte Caubel, secrétaire
d'Etat chargée de l'enfance.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Oui, les violences commises dans
le sein de la famille provoquent
des dommages extrêmement
importants pour nos enfants.
Oui, aujourd'hui, nous n'arrivons
pas à casser la chaîne de
violences au sein des familles.
Elles se reproduisent.
Il faut que l'on soit tous
mobilisés pour casser cette chaîne
de violences.
C'est la préoccupation de
l'ensemble des députés, sénateurs
et parlementaires, pour continuer
les travaux engagés dans le
grenelle contre les violences
faites aux femmes.
La création de cette aide
d'urgence est fondamentale pour
les femmes et les enfants
concernés.
Oui, il faut améliorer encore la
chaîne de traitement
poly-gendarmerie-justice.
Il faut mieux prendre en compte la
parole des enfants.
Oui, la place de l'enfant dans le
dispositif judiciaire doit induire
d'autres mesures.
Il faut donner une place à cet
administrateur ad hoc qui doit
accompagner l'enfant dans le
processus pénal.
Enfin, il faut prendre en compte
le préjudice des enfants.
Il faut entendre la parole.
Après, il faut accompagner ces
enfants auprès des départements.
Les départements s'y attellent
autant qu'ils le peuvent, avec les
associations.
Il faut renforcer les moyens et
coordonner l'action.
Tout cela, nous le ferons, mais
nous devons le faire avec tous les
adultes de ce pays, et les
familles.
Il faut prendre conscience de ça
et y mettre fin.
Merci, madame la députée, d'avoir
alerté sur cette question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Fabrice
Le Vigoureux.
- Fabrice Le Vigoureux: Ma
question s'adresse à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
Je souhaite vous interroger sur
les carrières d'enseignants et sur
la considération que nous devons à
toutes les femmes et les hommes
qui se sont engagés dans cette
action si noble et fondamentale
pour l'avenir de notre pays, celle
de transmettre des savoirs, des
savoir-faire et, de plus en plus,
des savoirs-être.
Ils forment des citoyens éclairés,
capables de voir dans notre
démocratie un bien précieux, et de
voir la parole s'exprimer sans
haine.
Ils assurent de respecter chacun,
malgré ses différences.
Quelle incroyable, formidable et
exigeante mission!
Le budget de l'Education nationale
est le premier de notre nation.
Il a augmenté de 21% depuis 2017,
à un rythme 2 fois plus soutenu
qu'au mandat socialiste précédent.
Cela pourrait amener certains à
l'humidité.
En moyenne, ces enseignants
bénéficient d'une hausse de leur
rémunération de 10% à compter de
la prochaine rentrée.
C'est un grand pas, l'amorce d'un
grand rattrapage.
C'est indispensable pour que nos
meilleurs étudiants reconsidèrent
l'enseignement comme une
voie attractive.
Alors, monsieur le ministre,
pouvez-vous nous préciser à
nouveau votre feuille de route
pour mieux reconnaître le métier
d'enseignant, si crucial pour
l'avenir de notre pays?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Vous l'avez dit, la question de
l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant est une priorité du
gouvernement.
En témoigne l'augmentation
importante du budget de
l'Education nationale cette année:
+6,5%.
J'ai ouvert, la semaine passée,
avec les organisations syndicales
représentatives, le cycle de
concertation sur l'attractivité et
la revalorisation du métier
d'enseignant.
Nous avons ouvert aujourd'hui les
concertations techniques pour
définir précisément, dans le
respect du dialogue social, les
mesures qui viendront contribuer à
restaurer l'attractivité du
métier, par une rémunération à
hauteur de l'engagement des
enseignants.
Cette revalorisation porte sur
deux dimensions: une
revalorisation socle, d'abord.
Cela signifie qu'elle va
concerner, dès la rentrée 2023, le
plus grand nombre possible
d'enseignants.
J'ai parlé des enseignants en
première moitié de carrière.
Mais il est possible aussi que les
enseignants en seconde moitié de
carrière soient concernés.
C'est un des points de la
concertation.
Deuxièmement, une revalorisation
liée à l'exercice de nouvelles
missions.
Les enseignants qui vont s'engager
dans ces nouvelles missions, que
nous allons définir en
concertation avec les
organisations syndicales, vont
recevoir une augmentation
supplémentaire de 10%, pour un
total de 20% pour les enseignants
concernés.
L'objectif est de conclure la
concertation au mois de mars, afin
de mettre en oeuvre ces mesures
pour le 1er septembre 2023.
Cet engagement du gouvernement, il
traduit bien notre considération
pour les professeurs et le fait
que les professeurs doivent être
mieux payés, mieux traités, et
c'est précisément ce que nous
allons faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Lionel
Tivoli.
- Lionel Tivoli: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Merci.
La question s'adresse au ministre
des Finances.
Il est révolu le temps où la
France était cette nation
puissante et, surtout,
indépendante.
Depuis 30 ans maintenant, les
prétendues élites qui ont gouverné
notre pays ont dilapidé nos
intérêts stratégiques majeurs au
profit de la commission européen.
Les gouvernements successifs n'ont
conduit notre pays qu'à la ruine
et au désastre.
Nous sommes désormais sous la
tutelle de l'Union Européenne.
Nous sommes asservis à l'Union
Européenne.
Encore aujourd'hui, nous adhérons
au marché européen de
l'électricité.
C'est une aberration économique et
écologique qui consiste à vendre
notre énergie nucléaire décarbonée
à partir du gaz et du charbon à
des prix exorbitants.
Nous sommes asservis à l'Union
Européenne, quand la semaine
dernière encore, la cour de
justice de l'Union Européenne, au
nom de la primauté du droit
européen, a annoncé l'interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes pour les
agriculteurs européens, alors même
que des produits agricoles qui
viennent du bout du monde se
vendent et se consomment chaque
jour sur notre marché commun.
Ils ont été traités par ces
produits interdits dans l'Union
Européenne.
Comment allez-vous expliquer aux
producteurs de betteraves qu'ils
ne pourront plus utiliser les
néonicotinoïdes pour ne pas tuer
les abeilles, abeilles qui ne
butinent pas sur la betterave?
La Banque centrale européenne ne
maîtrise plus l'inflation.
Les chèques énergie ont été
distribués comme une aumône.
Nos entreprises sont à l'agonie.
Les Français peinent à se
chauffer.
Les agriculteurs subissent une
concurrence de plus en plus
déloyale.
Quand allez-vous arrêter de céder
aux sirènes de Bruxelles?
A partir de quand allez-vous vous
soucier de l'avenir des Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Vous avez, comme souvent, tout
mélangé, dans votre question.
Si ce n'est une seule chose: vous
racontez n'importe quoi sur
l'Europe!
La réalité, c'est que sur le
marché de l'énergie, monsieur le
député, s'il n'y avait pas eu le
marché de l'énergie, nous
n'aurions pas eu assez
d'électricité pour éclairer cette
salle.
Nous importions de l'électricité
allemande.
Aujourd'hui, nos industriels et
nos ménages bénéficient d'une
facture d'énergie inférieure à la
plupart des autres pays européens.
La réalité, c'est que ça fait des
années que vous faites votre
beurre sur les difficultés
économiques et sociales des
entreprises et des ménages
français.
La réalité, c'est que pendant que
vous vous nourrissez des
difficultés des autres, nous
sommes à leurs côtés.
Le ministre de l'Agriculture est
aux côtés des producteurs de
betteraves.
Vous ne faites qu'une seule chose:
sauter comme un cabri en disant
qu'il faut sortir de l'Europe.
Nous y sommes et nous la
changeons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Davy
Rimane.
- Davy Rimane: Merci.
Alors qu'une autre réforme des
retraites est possible avec des
mesures autres que le recul de
l'âge de départ, que votre propre
ministre reconnaît que les femmes
vont être les premières à être
pénalisées par le report de l'âge
légal, vous poursuivez une réforme
injuste et inefficace.
Nous, les peu, les chiens, les
riens, les nègres...
Comment se fait-il que 77 ans
après la départementalisation des
vieilles colonies, ce problème
reste criant d'actualité?
Pouvez-vous m'expliquer comment
cette réforme va s'appliquer à nos
territoires?
La réalité est celle des réalités
fragmentées.
Vous précarisez nos peuples.
C'est non.
Pensez-vous réellement qu'une
telle réforme réponde à l'urgence
que traversent les Français?
J'aimerais terminer en
paraphrasant Aimé Césaire.
"Quand allons-nous cesser d'être
le jouet des autres?
Nous n'allons plus nous contenter
d'assister à la politique des
autres."
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
La dernière fois que j'ai entendu
une telle citation, c'était de la
part de Christiane Taubira.
Je suis toujours à gauche,
monsieur.
Vous, vous êtes passé à l'extrême
gauche.
Nous sommes bien conscients des
difficultés rencontrées par les
territoires d'outre-mer.
J'aimerais simplement vous dire
qu'il y a trois sujets qui me
viennent à l'esprit quand vous
évoquez les territoires
d'outre-mer autour de la question
des retraites.
Nous avons encore du travail,
premièrement.
Il faut que les partenaires
sociaux se saisissent de la
nécessité d'élargir la couverture
Agirc-Arrco à un certain nombre de
salariés.
Nous avons aussi un travail à
faire pour achever des périodes de
convergence.
Je pense notamment à Mayotte.
Il y a un troisième point.
C'est le fruit de l'histoire
économique et sociale de ces
territoires.
Vous nous dites que notre réforme
va trop loin et que nous ne
devrions pas relever l'âge de
départ de la retraite.
Quand on regarde l'âge effectif de
départ, je parle d'âge d'ouverture
des droits, nous constatons qu'en
Guyane, en Martinique ou en
Guadeloupe, nous sommes autour de
65 ans.
C'est parfois le résultat de
carrières hachées.
- Davy Rimane: Nous avons envoyé
un courrier pour une rencontre
assez rapide, pour parler d'un
certain nombre de choses.
On n'a pas eu de réponse de votre
part.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Lionel
Royer-Perreaut.
- Lionel Royer-Perreaut: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
des Armées.
J'y associe mes collègues.
Monsieur le ministre, vous le
savez mieux que quiconque, nos
armées ont, par le passé, été trop
longtemps négligées, pour ne pas
dire abîmées.
Trop d'espoirs déçus par des lois
de programmation militaire
amputées de leurs ambitions
initiales, avec pour conséquence,
des capacités militaires
dégradées.
En 2018, la majorité
présidentielle a adopté une loi de
programmation militaire de
réparation.
Fait rarissime dans l'histoire:
elle a été intégralement respectée
et exécutée.
Dans un monde incertain, aux
menaces hybrides et évolutives, la
France se devait de se doter d'une
nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire ambitieuse, qui s'adapte
au nouveau contexte
géo-stratégique.
Le président de la République a
annoncé la semaine dernière un
effort budgétaire sans équivalent,
de 413 milliards d'euros.
C'est pour permettre à la France
de rester une puissance militaire
mondiale.
413 milliards d'euros pour assurer
la sécurité des Français et
garantir la protection de notre
pays.
413 milliards d'euros pour adapter
nos armées aux nouvelles menaces,
mais aussi pour consolider notre
dissuasion nucléaire.
413 milliards d'euros, enfin, pour
mieux équiper nos filles et fils
de France, et pour venir en
soutien à nos forces armées.
Car oui, cet effort aux armées,
nous leurs devons.
Vous allez être auditionné à 17h
par la commission de Défense
nationale et des forces armées,
pouvez-vous nous indiquer en quoi
cette somme historique constitue
un effort politique, budgétaire,
militaire, et technologique
inédit?
Je vous en remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu.
- Sébastien Lecornu: Merci.
Vous êtes revenu sur les efforts
précédents de réparation.
Désormais, nous sommes dans une
séquence différente, où ces lois
de programmation doivent définir
un format d'armée, qui doit nous
permettre de répondre à des
menaces.
Certaines menaces sont bien
connues.
Il y a notamment le terrorisme,
dont on ne parle plus assez.
Quand on interroge la somme, il
faut savoir que ces nouveaux
espaces nécessitent des sauts
technologiques importants, qui
sont assez coûteux.
C'est un défi, qui s'impose à
nous, de rester dans le match des
compétitions avec d'autres
puissances ou d'autres menaces.
Il faut préciser que notre format
d'armée est défensif.
Nous avons donné le cadre,
l'ambition et la stratégie.
Il va falloir clarifier dans quel
contexte la France entend évoluer
avec son armée.
Une nouvelle période de
consultation de notre base
industrielle et technologique de
défense va s'ouvrir.
J'ai signé ce matin un mandat pour
faire un premier tour de piste de
nos industriels.
C'est aussi pour définir les
stocks et les calendriers de
livraison.
Cela va nous permettre, aux
alentours du mois de mars ou
avril, de présenter cette loi de
programmation militaire en Conseil
des ministres, et de venir devant
vous à l'horizon du mois de mai ou
juin prochain.
J'aurai l'occasion de répondre à
vos questions en commission, dans
un instant.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Karen
Erodi.
- Karen Erodi: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
En mars dernier, Emmanuel Macron
disait que nous n'avions pas le
droit de régresser sur le sujet
des retraites entre les femmes et
les hommes.
Pour une fois, je vais donner
raison au ministre.
Votre réforme va toucher plus
durement les femmes.
Nous, les femmes, devrons
travailler plus longtemps que les
hommes.
L'âge de départ à la retraite des
femmes nées dans les années 80 va
augmenter deux fois plus que celui
des hommes.
Nous, les femmes, aurons une
retraite plus faible, alors que
nos pensions sont déjà inférieures
de 40% à celles des hommes.
Reporter de deux ans l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite revient à
ôter aux femmes 24 mois de
pensions, soit une perte de 40.000
euros sur une retraite cumulée.
Une femme qui part à 64 ans devait
vivre jusqu'à 153 ans pour
bénéficier de la retraite.
C'est absurde!
Votre réforme est une réforme
contre les femmes.
Vous aviez dit que votre projet
portait des progrès concrets pour
les femmes.
Allez-vous pourrir la vie des
aides-soignantes, des employés, de
toutes les femmes de ce pays?
Nous devrions nous mettre à genoux
pour vous remercier de nous
permettre de travailler jusqu'à 65
ans pour obtenir la retraite à
taux plein?
Madame la Première ministre,
allez-vous continuer encore
longtemps à vous essuyer les pieds
sur votre grande cause du
quinquennat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Vous avez débuté votre question en
disant que les femmes allaient
devoir travailler plus longtemps
que les hommes.
C'est une affirmation lapidaire et
mensongère.
L'âge légal de départ des femmes,
comme des hommes, est le même.
La durée de cotisation requise
telle que votée en 2013 est
évidemment la même.
Ce que montre l'étude d'impact,
c'est que, progressivement, l'âge
effectif des femmes va se
rapprocher de celui des hommes.
Il y a certains rapprochements,
mais cela reste inférieur.
Vous dites que nous demanderions
aux femmes de travailler plus
longtemps, ce qui est mensonger.
Toutes les mesures que nous avons
prises visent à mieux protéger les
femmes, notamment les plus
fragiles.
Tenir compte des trimestres
cotisés, c'est une mesure de
protection des femmes.
La seule mise en oeuvre de la
retraite minimum garantie, quand
on sait que 50% des retraitées
femmes ont une retraite inférieure
à 1000 euros brut par mois, c'est
une mesure qui protège les femmes.
C'est en particulier pour les
femmes qui ont les carrières les
plus hachées, et donc les plus
basses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Vous avez une seconde.
- Christian Baptiste: Madame la
présidente, chers collègues.
Il y a quelques jours, mon
collègue vous interrogeait sur
l'impact de la réforme des
retraites dans les territoires
d'outre-mer.
La question revêt une importance
particulière.
Le projet a vocation à s'appliquer
en France hexagonale mais aussi
sur les territoires d'outre-mer.
Monsieur le ministre, comment
pensez-vous une réforme
universelle
sans prendre en compte les
spécificités des territoires
ultramarins?
Le chômage systémique et les
spécificités structurelles et
économiques de nos territoires
exposent nos travailleurs à des
carrières hachées,
sous-rémunérées, ne leur
permettant pas de partir le moment
venu avec une pension décente et
complète.
9 à 15% de nos retraités
d'outre-mer sont considérés comme
en situation de grande pauvreté.
Un retraité qui réside en
territoire d'outre-mer touche, en
moyenne, une pension inférieure de
10 à 17% à celle que perçoit un
senior vivant en France
hexagonale.
Ma question est la suivante:
pouvez-vous nous garantir que le
projet de réforme des retraites
introduit par vos soins est de
nature à garantir une équité de
traitement entre les retraités de
la France hexagonale et ceux des
territoires d'outre-mer?
Merci de nous indiquer précisément
les paramètres...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député, je voudrais
vous apporter des précisions sur
la prise en compte des
spécificités d'outre-mer.
La réforme s'appliquera aux
départements d'outre-mer.
La situation de Mayotte est aussi
particulière.
Le régime obligatoire de retraite
ne date que de 1987.
Les retraités actuels ont une
carrière composée en général de 9
années cotisées.
Cela se traduit par des retraites
très basses et des modalités de
calcul particulières et adaptés.
Il y a ensuite un chantier que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
concernant les salariés agricoles
dans les territoires de Guadeloupe
et de La Réunion, qui nécessite
que les partenaires sociaux
puissent travailler pour étendre
la couverture à ces territoires
mais comment cette réforme
va-t-elle s'étendre aux
territoires d'outre-mer?
L'appliquer de manière similaire à
ce qui se passera en France
hexagonale va permettre de
prolonger les carrières dans les
territoires où l'âge de départ est
déjà supérieur au prochain âge
légal d'ouverture des droits.
Une autre caractéristique de la
réforme bénéficiait aux outre-mer:
la réévaluation de la pension
minimale à 85% du SMIC.
C'est conditionné à une carrière
complète.
L'augmentation du minimum
contributif majoré sera assurée
aux retraités ayant cotisé 120
trimestres dans leur carrière.
Beaucoup vont pouvoir en
bénéficier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Bolo.
- Philippe Bolo: Merci.
Après les côtes du Finistère en
décembre et celles de la Vendée en
janvier, ce sont les rivages de la
Loire-Atlantique qui sont souillés
par des billes de plastique.
Par millions, les objets de
plastique envahissent les zones
littorales.
Le nettoyage et si fastidieux
qu'il en devient impossible.
Les dégâts sont terribles pour la
faune marine ainsi que le
tourisme.
Sans parler de la présence durable
de ces plastiques.
Des plaintes ont été déposées
contre X.
Plusieurs associations ont aussi
saisi la justice.
L'Etat a lui-même décidé de porter
plainte.
Comment envisagez-vous de
mobiliser vos services
scientifiques et techniques afin
de mener les investigations
indispensables pour identifier la
source de pollution et ses
responsables?
L'arrivée de plastique sur nos
côtes montre que le programme de
l'industrie plastique pour éviter
les rejets dans l'environnement
est insuffisant.
Des moyens de contrôle ont-ils été
mis en place pour s'assurer de
l'application de ce que nous avons
voté dans cet hémicycle?
La pollution marine par des billes
de plastique est un phénomène
mondial qui impose une prise de
conscience internationale.
Envisagez-vous de porter la voix
de la France sur ce sujet lors de
la deuxième session des
négociations du traité
international sur la pollution
plastique qui se déroulera au
printemps 2023?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés.
Ce que nous vivons est un scandale
absolu.
Une marée blanche qui, après la
Vendée, le Finistère le Morbihan,
touche la Loire-Atlantique.
Nous parlons de granulés de
plastique de 4 à 5 millimètres de
diamètre qui atteignent parfois
des concentrations de 200 granulés
par mètre carré.
Ils sont compliqués à ramasser.
Ils sont ingérés par les animaux.
Ils s'intègrent à l'écosystème.
Ils laissent dans le désarroi les
associations qui essayent de se
mobiliser.
Le gouvernement est révolté et
joint la parole aux actes.
Nous avons signé le dépôt de
plainte auprès du procureur de la
République.
Les experts du centre de
documentation et de recherche sont
sur place pour regarder les
procédés afin d'améliorer
l'exfiltration mais surtout pour
déterminer d'où ça vient.
La loi a posé un principe en 2020.
Les décrets d'application ont été
pris depuis le 1er janvier 2022.
Notre pays est un des rares à
imposer à tous les dispositifs
industriels des séparations, des
filtres qui permettent de capter
ces billes.
Les audits sont pour la première
année sur le point d'être rendus
publics.
Un certain nombre d'armateurs
indélicats ont laissé s'échapper
ces billes en plastique sans rien
dire.
La nécessité d'agir est
importante.
A la fin du mois de mai, à
l'Unesco, la France va accueillir
une concertation pour
l'élimination des rejets de
plastique.
Nous en parlerons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Christelle
Petex-Levet.
- Christelle Petex-Levet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
La France connaît un point de
non-retour de notre système de santé.
La question paraît peut-être
redondante, mais elle est toujours
au coeur des préoccupations de
chaque citoyen.
Son importance est capitale.
Pas un jour au cours duquel nous
ne sommes pas sollicités à ce
sujet.
Que répondre?
Tous les secteurs se sentent
incompris face à la pénurie de
soignants, à la saturation au sein
des établissements ainsi qu'aux
conditions de travail dégradées.
Quand ils font des propositions,
ils ne sont pas soutenus ou
n'entrent pas dans les projets de
l'Etat.
Il nous faut un objectif commun
adapté à chaque territoire.
Les soignants partent travailler
en Suisse voisine.
Pour soigner notre système de
santé, ayant du bon sens.
Eliminons les consultations
inutiles.
Revenons au choix de médecin libre.
Valorisons les salaires et les
consultations.
Révisons les tâches
administratives et réintégrons les
soignants non-vaccinés.
Que cherchez-vous?
Les professionnels de santé ne
sont pas responsables des erreurs
de la politique de santé des
gouvernements successifs qui ont
mené à la crise actuelle.
Le plan annoncé récemment ne
suffira pas.
Quand allez-vous réellement
engager la responsabilité des
actions efficaces et durables pour
notre système de santé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Madame la
députée Christelle Petex-Levet,
merci de confirmer que la
dégradation du système ne vient
pas d'aujourd'hui ni de ces
dernières années, mais de
décennies de destruction de notre
système de santé.
L'objectif est clair pour le
gouvernement: prendre soin et des
Français mais aussi de ceux qui
les soignent.
Beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
faites.
Je ne reviens pas sur la
suppression du numerus clausus ou
le Ségur de la santé.
Nous devons aller plus loin.
Le président de la République a
fixé trois principes issus des CNR
de territoire.
Il faut arrêter la concurrence
entre le public et le privé.
Il faut travailler sur des
organisations à l'échelle humaine
et revenir à la notion de service
par territoire.
Dans les six mois qui viennent,
outre l'augmentation des
formations, nous voulons redonner
du temps aux soignants.
Les soignants ne doivent faire que
du soin.
Il faut un exercice en remettant
des personnes à l'administratif
auprès des services.
La plus-value des personnels de
santé doit être reconnue dans les
parcours de soins.
Il faut un médecin traitant par
personne avant la fin de l'année.
Les professionnels de santé
verront reconnue la pénibilité, la
qualité de vie au travail.
Il faut travailler avec les
territoires.
L'attractivité est différente et
la fuite des professionnels est
différente également.
- Christelle Petex-Levet: De
grands discours, c'est bien.
Réagir de façon immédiate, c'est
mieux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Sandra Regol.
- Sandra Regol: Merci.
Vendredi dernier, l'élection de
notre collègue a été annulée dans
la 9e circonscription des Français
hors de France.
Vous avez fait une erreur.
Votre faute punie des électeurs et
électrices de cette
circonscription.
Cela les prive des élus au service
de la démocratie et des
concitoyens.
Le Conseil constitutionnel jugé
garant des élections a constaté
des dysfonctionnements dans
l'envoi de SMS permettant aux
électeurs d'Algérie de voter en
ligne.
Alors même que cette circonstance
n'est imputable ni au candidat élu
ni aux autres candidats, il y a
lieu d'annuler les élections.
L'organisation du vote à
l'étranger est votre
responsabilité.
L'annulation prononcée par le
Conseil constitutionnel est votre
échec.
Pourtant, vos services n'ont cessé
d'envoyer à nos compatriotes des
messages faisant l'éloge de
l'organisation de ce vote
électronique.
Comment assurer à tous les
électeurs concernés que cette
procédure est et reste fiable?
Que faites-vous pour garantir le
droit de vote effectif de nos
compatriotes établis au Maghreb et
en Afrique de l'Ouest lors de la
prochaine élection qui arrive sous
peu?
Il reste le vote à l'urne, mais
les bureaux de vote sont trop peu
nombreux et trop éloignés.
En 2017, le gouvernement avait
renoncé à organiser un vote
électronique, privant de nombreux
compatriotes trop éloignés des
bureaux de vote.
Ma question est simple: allez-vous
enfin essayer de donner les moyens
de lutter contre l'abstention des
Français habitant hors de France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Laurence
Boone.
- Laurence Boone: Effectivement,
le Conseil constitutionnel a rendu
deux décisions par lesquelles il a
décidé l'annulation des élections
s'étant déroulées dans la 2e et 9e
circonscription des Français de
l'étranger.
Ceci portait sur des problèmes de
réception par certains électeurs
en Argentine, et pas qu'en
Algérie, de mots de passe et
identifiants requit pour voter sur
Internet.
Les électeurs devaient en effet
renseigner un mot de passe reçu
par SMS et un identifiant reçu par
courriel.
Ce recours à deux canaux distincts
relevait de la sécurité.
L'opérateur téléphonique retenu
avait tout fait pour remédier aux
dysfonctionnements constatés, mais
n'y est parvenu auprès de tous les
opérateurs téléphoniques à
l'étranger.
Le gouvernement est attaché au
progrès qu'a représenté le vote
électronique, qui a permis
d'accroître fortement la
participation des Français de
l'étranger aux élections
législatives.
Nous tirons les enseignements de
cette première utilisation du vote
électronique afin d'allier la plus
grande sécurité à notre souhait
d'un accès large au vote pour nos
concitoyens de l'étranger.
Nous maintiendrons ces votes
électroniques améliorés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Carel.
- Agnès Carel: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse, comme beaucoup de mes
collègues et beaucoup de Français,
je suis inquiète du manque
d'enseignants remplaçants.
Dans ma circonscription, j'ai été
interpellée par des directeurs
d'écoles et des parents d'élèves
qui se trouvent démunis face à des
classes sans remplaçants.
Dans une des écoles, nous sommes à
92 jours sans école depuis la
rentrée pour certains élèves.
Dans une autre école, depuis le 30
novembre, des élèves se retrouvent
sans enseignante.
Beaucoup d'élèves sont répartis
dans les autres classes.
Les autres enseignants pallient,
dans l'urgence.
Les élèves peinent à s'adapter.
Les enseignants se retrouvent avec
des classes surchargées.
Il a été parfois conseillé aux
parents de garder leurs enfants à
la maison.
Dans une autre classe, une
enseignante est parfois remplacée
une heure le matin et doit laisser
les élèves l'après-midi.
Nous savons que les recrutements
sont difficiles et qu'à la
rentrée, le nombre d'heures
d'enseignant était insuffisant.
Les heures d'enseignement perdues
pour ces enfants ne seront jamais
remplacées.
L'appétence est là, mais pas
l'enseignant.
Le retard, le manque d'acquis dans
les fondamentaux, la démotivation
et même la perte de repères dans
une classe qui n'est pas le leur,
sans parler des sorties scolaires,
ont des conséquences non
négligeables pour ces élèves.
Quelles mesures pérennes
allez-vous mettre en place pour
que chaque classe de chaque
établissement de France puisse
disposer de remplaçants et de
solutions pour donner à chaque
parent la visibilité en plaçant
des meilleurs délais?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
La question du remplacement des
enseignants est essentielle pour
la continuité pédagogique.
Dans le premier degré, il existe
un dispositif spécifique, celui
des brigades de remplacement, qui
rassemble 9% des effectifs de
professeurs.
Le premier degré est touché par
des difficultés de recrutement, y
compris les brigades de
remplacement.
Nous devons répondre à cela par
trois voix.
La première est celle de la
revalorisation.
La seconde, pour les territoires
les plus en difficulté, c'est
l'organisation de concours
exceptionnels pour titulariser les
professeurs contractuels.
Le concours est ouvert dans les
académies de Créteil, de
Versailles et de Guyane.
De manière plus structurelle, nous
devons réfléchir au recrutement et
à la formation des professeurs des
écoles.
Par exemple, par le recrutement et
la formation d'élèves-professeurs
qui seraient titularisés au bout
de 5 ans.
C'est une hypothèse sur laquelle
nous travaillons actuellement.
S'agissant du second degré, la
question du remplacement doit
aussi être prise à bras-le-corps,
d'une part par la revalorisation
mais aussi par les missions
complémentaires qui font l'objet
de concertation et qui incluent
cette question des remplacements
de courte durée.
Ce qui est en jeu, ce sont les
remplacements de courte durée, de
moins de deux semaines, qui ont en
effet des effets parfois très
dommageables sur la continuité
pédagogique dans un certain nombre
de départements.
Nous nous attelons à cette
question.
Vous verrez la différence à partir
de la rentrée prochaine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Delogu.
- Sébastien Delogu: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, c'est avec une immense
émotion que je m'adresse à vous,
accompagné du collectif des
familles de victimes d'assassinat
présent aujourd'hui.
Il y a six mois, j'ai été élu
député, mais au quotidien, j'ai
l'impression de travailler pour
les pompes funèbres.
Chaque semaine, je marche dans le
sang.
Marseille, c'est 500 homicides
depuis que j'y vis.
C'est 66 fusillades, 36 meurtres
l'année dernière.
L'année 2022 est la plus
meurtrière.
La semaine dernière, un père de
famille de 46 ans s'est fait tuer
d'une balle dans la tête dans le
quartier de mon enfance.
L'insécurité rend nos quartiers de
plus en plus sinistres et les
habitants des quartiers pauvres de
Marseille ont aussi droit à une
sûreté.
Que se passe-t-il?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Comme vous, je m'inquiète de ce
qui se passe à Marseille depuis de
trop longues années.
Ceci est le fait d'une guerre de
gangs, de points de deal, une
guerre de la drogue qui endeuille
la cité marseillaise depuis trop
longtemps.
Dans l'assassinat dont vous
parliez, la personne était connue
des services de police.
Vous savez que la situation que
nous trouvons à Marseille est
malheureusement une situation de
règlements de compte.
Malgré les nombreux meurtres qui
existent à Marseille, 29 ont été
évités en 2022 par les services de
police.
Vous pourriez d'ailleurs les
soutenir un peu plus plutôt que de
les insulter comme vous l'avez
fait encore récemment.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Sébastien Delogu?
- Sébastien Delogu: Vos éléments
de langage ne changeront rien.
Il faut changer votre politique
contre la drogue et le trafic
d'armes.
Il faut arrêter votre politique du
chiffre qui ne fonctionne pas donc
je vous demande, en tant que
député des Bouches-du-Rhône, de
démanteler la BAC, de mettre en
place une police de proximité qui
rétablisse les liens avec la
population.
Agissez vite.
Nos quartiers s'embrasent.
Les habitants des quartiers
populaires sont-ils, eux, des
Français à part?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous voulez
démanteler les policiers la BAC,
nous voulons démanteler les
trafics de drogue.
Vos propos, comme tous ceux de La
France Insoumise, sont scandaleux.
Vous nous dites que les policiers
sont des barbares.
Soyez prudent!
Les vérités sont très bonnes à
écouter de la part de ceux qui
n'aiment pas la police.
Ce sont les policiers qui sont
courageux dans les cités de
Marseille, pas les voyous.
Vous devriez avoir honte de
soutenir ceux qui attaquent les
policiers.
Vive la police nationale, qui
protège nos honnêtes citoyens!
Plutôt que de dire que les
policiers sont des barbares,
plutôt que de vouloir démanteler
la police nationale, vous devriez
vouloir protéger la police plutôt
que d'être complice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Non, il n'y a pas deux
interventions.
La parole est à madame Nathalie da
Conceicao Carvalho.
- Nathalie Da Conceicao Carvalho:
Merci.
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux,
vendredi dernier, le meurtrier de
la jeune Axelle Daurier a été
condamné à 12 ans de prison.
Bon nombre de nos compatriotes
sont choqués, notamment après
avoir entendu l'avocat du coupable
expliquer qu'il pourra, dès
l'année prochaine, bénéficier d'un
bracelet probatoire.
Voilà une triste illustration de
votre politique pénale.
Rappels à la loi, stages de
citoyenneté, travaux d'intérêt
général, peines de prison avec
sursis, voilà ce que risquent ceux
qui volent, rackettent, insultent,
trafiquent.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2023, tout
condamné à moins de 2 ans de
prison sort trois mois avant la
fin de sa peine.
Il y a des exceptions à la règle,
mais vous laisser sortir des
coupables de trafics de
stupéfiants, de violences avec ou
sans armes.
Si l'actualité politico-judiciaire
n'évoquait pas si régulièrement
des récidivistes, on pourrait se
dire que c'est la notion même de
justice qui est mise à mal.
Dans les faits, ce sont nos
compatriotes qui font les frais de
cette justice.
Je vous le redis clairement.
Il y aura, un jour, un raté.
Depuis des décennies, la politique
des peines repose sur un dogme:
éviter de sanctionner.
Lorsque des peines sont
prononcées, on évite la prison.
Les libérations anticipées
inquiètent les Français.
Quand allez-vous changer de
politique pénale?
Quand mettrez-vous en place une
politique pénale qui protège les
Français et leur rende confiance
en la justice?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Madame la députée, d'un extrême à
l'autre, toujours les vieilles
mêmes recettes, les mêmes
casseroles et les mêmes produits,
qui donnent de mauvais plat.
Si on change de politique pénale
pour aller vers la vôtre...
Vous critiquez une décision de
justice rendue par la souveraineté
populaire.
Bel hommage que vous lui rendez!
Je vous dis ensuite que la
Constitution n'est pas un texte
superfétatoire, mais un texte qui
consacre la totale indépendance de
la justice dans notre pays.
Le jour où, comme vous le
souhaitez, on touchera à
l'indépendance de la justice, nous
aurons basculé vers le
totalitarisme.
S'agissant des libérations sous
contraintes, vous retenez le mot
"libérations".
Il faut aussi entendre le mot
"contraintes".
Il s'agit d'interdire des sorties
sèches.
Cela concerne les gens condamnés à
qui il reste moins de 2 ans
d'environnement.
Cela consiste en une libération
sous contraintes et sous le
contrôle d'un juge, qui ne peut
être envisagé que s'il y a un
hébergement...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît, monsieur Chenu!
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Que s'il y
a un hébergement.
41% ont bénéficié d'une libération
sous contraintes.
60% n'en ont donc pas bénéficié.
Ca consacre la réinsertion et la
lutte contre la récidive mais vous
ne comprenez rien à la procédure
pénale, si ce n'est la trique!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.